[MUSIC PLAYING]
Something that is
useful to know about MIT
is that it's like
drinking from a fire hose.
They will often tell you about
this in tours and everything,
too, but you really get to
experience it when you first
start your classes.
So there's lots
of great research
to do at MIT, a lot of great
classes to take as well.
But I think what
maybe some people
don't know about is that there's
lots of really cool activities
you can get involved with.
There's a sailing club.
You can do rowing.
There's any number of
different activities
you can get involved
with while you're here.
I think people should know
that MIT has a lot to offer.
Which means that
you'll have lots
of classes, lots of
extracurriculars,
lots of sports options.
And so that means
that, basically, you
can be overwhelmed with the
number of things going on,
and just to pick and choose.
Drink them all in, but
be choosy about what
you should do with your time
and what you should work on.
The people here
are really great.
And I think that the people are
what makes this place special.
So in my experience,
not only are people here
obviously really
smart, but I think
they're also super
down to earth,
very easy to talk to
and have conversations
with-- not just about academics,
but also stuff outside of that.
And so I found
that it's actually
been a surprisingly
balanced place in terms
of, yeah, just interests.
And also I think
that a lot of people
here, because they are so
passionate about what they
do and love what
they do so much,
they're always happy
to talk about it
and want to have
conversations about it.
So I think people may
sometimes be intimidated.
But I would say, yeah,
don't be intimidated
in talking to people.
And everyone I think
is, in general,
quite welcoming around here.
Well, MIT is a super
collaborative environment.
So do not hesitate to reach
out to people around you
and explore any potential future
projects that you could work on
together.
Because everyone has
a unique expertise.
So by working together, you
can achieve greater things.
So I think that there are
things that I could say related
to your coursework or to
the intellectual inquiry
that you'll do and how
to think about research.
But I think what maybe
is more important
than any of that to
your long-term success
in the program is
finding a group of people
that you resonate with.
And I think sometimes
people come into the program
and they get in a local minima,
where they're surrounded
by a certain type
of people, and they
think that this is true for
the rest of the community.
And that's not the case.
And you can find people
that will resonate with you
and make you feel like
you're growing and learning
in the right ways and make
you feel like you belong.
And so if you're
interacting with people
that don't make you
feel like you belong,
there's someone else
that you can work with.
I think it's really, really
important that you know
how to take care of yourself.
So if you come to MIT, you
need to find a support network.
And you need to rely
on those people.
Because it's going to be
hard if you come here.
That's the nature of the
work that we're doing,
and it's the nature
of the Institute.
And so finding those
friends, finding
those people you can rely on,
that will get you through.
It's cold, but you
can deal with it.
It takes a little bit
of suffering tolerance.
[MUSIC PLAYING]